Here's a quick quiz reviewing why we use training and testing data.
Check all the answers that apply.
The first option is that using separate training and testing data allows you to
make an estimate of the performance of your classifier or
your regression on an independent dataset.
The second option is that having separate training and
testing data serves as a check on overfitting.
The third possibility is that the training testing split is kind of deep and
mysterious, but the experts tell us we should do it, so, that's why we do it.
And the last option is that since it's so important to have as much training
data as you possibly can, separating your dataset into training and testing data
helps you maximize the amount of data that's available for training.